in Captain America Civil War we're
looking at the repercussions of all of
the Marvel movies up to this point so
the war is about the government saying
hold on a second Avengers just because
you can be first responders across the
globe doesn't mean you should be all
superheroes should be registered there
should no longer be vigilantes cap
believes there's one course of action
that should take and Tony believe
there's another there's this rift and we
put their relationship in the balance as
well as the Avengers
we wanted to have a third party who
wasn't even necessarily involved in that
argument and we kept talking up like
pepper
he's a monarch and at the same time he's
this superhero but there's a certain
mystery about the character fun thing
about civil war is it's almost as many
players as we've ever had in our films
showing up together so Wanda Maximoff
for instance who we saw struggle with
her abilities in Ultron we see exactly
how powerful she is she's more
understanding of her skills and she has
like quite a great amount emotional
journey in this one it's not villain
versus hero it's it's friends it's
family Civil War is the right movie in
the right moment for where the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is and for where
these characters are it's gonna
challenge the way that you think about
Tony Stark it's going to challenge the
way that you think about Steve Rogers
and when you come out of that film
nothing will be the same
hey youtubers is Charlie so new Captain
America Civil War behind-the-scenes
footage let's talk a little bit about
what's going on with Black Panther at
the movie they actually they gave us a
little bit of a tease but we have a
pretty good idea so the way the Russos
are talking about Black Panther in this
movie make it sound like he has almost
nothing to do with what's going on
between Captain America and Iron Man the
the sokovia accords like the big line in
the sand it's drawn it's a little more
helpful if you think about it in the
context of comic books Civil War it's
really like a gun control issue like
Tony Stark wants gun control so he wants
to issue all these regulations Captain
America is all about civil liberties so
that's where they draw the line in the
sand but in this movie it sounds like
black panther isn't in on any of that
why then is he kicking the out of
Winter Soldier in this trailer
maybe his interest in this matter is
purely to tracked down Winter Soldier
now in the comics Winter Soldier has
killed a lot of people they they kind of
address that during the Winter Soldier
movie you just kind of seen in montage
like he killed Kennedy killed a bunch of
important people but in the comics he
also killed Tony Stark's parents so
maybe what the movie is going to do is
take a little bit of that and give it to
Black Panthers character like you
assassinated my father so I'm going to
come after you Winter Soldier himself is
kind of a tangential thing in the movie
because the governments of the world
sound like they're the ones that draft
these sokovia accords like look we don't
want Avengers or even villains for that
matter going out unchecked we like to
make sure that everyone is accountable
to someone else
so really accountability is the issue
here like who do the Avengers answer to
if they are the ultimate power in the
world you can kind of see the darkest
timeline version of this where it gets
into Watchmen territory like that's like
the cynical version of this but black
panther just based on the footage we've
seen of him in the trailer so far looks
like he's on par with Captain America in
terms of abilities now black panther
himself is just born a normal human
being
his powers mostly flow from the panther
totem in these special herbs that he
eats but he's also wearing a vibranium
suit so I'm assuming there's some tech
involved in there too will conned out
one of the most advanced rich nations in
the world monetarily rich that is just
because of vibranium so however you want
to explain it I mean you could just
explain it with vibranium suit like he's
wearing a special suit makes him super
powerful but in the comics it goes a
little bit deeper than that there are
mystical aspects to his abilities but in
terms of fighting ability in this movie
looks like he's about on par with
Captain America and Winter Soldier
that's
the point of the movie you know making
sure that everyone's evenly matched
because they're all friends fighting
with each other they don't want you to
have a clear favorite even though it's
Captain America's movie he's probably
gonna be the one you walk away with
identifying the most speaking of
fighting abilities what about Scarlet
Witch and vision because they did say
you know Scarlet Witch very much more in
command of her abilities in this movie
but she has a much more emotional arc so
I'm guessing that's gonna be her
Achilles heel like they balanced all the
characters in some way like Hulk can't
control his abilities so yeah he could
be super powerful if he had the mind of
Banner when he was the Hulk Black Widow
very capable amazing fighter but doesn't
have the gear that the other people have
so she's not quite as strong so
everybody has their own weaknesses that
kind of help balance them out vision is
the real question mark though I'm
curious to see why he hasn't appeared in
any of these trailers they probably had
a hard time keeping him from turning
into this deus ex machina character
because he wields an infinity stone and
he has no loyalties to any of the
characters over other characters like I
think the idea is that he's the most
objective character possible like he's
probably been mused with the idea of all
these internal politics that are going
on on the earth that's actually good
question for you guys let me know in the
comments what do you think that vision
is gonna be doing in this movie because
it sounds like he's gonna wind up being
team Iron Man so like what is going to
happen to keep him from just shutting
everyone down at the same time because
he's more powerful than anyone else so
there has to be a really compelling
reason for him to just not go out and
like capture everyone else when they
refuse to sign in sokovia accords but in
related news there is some new Doctor
Strange video so I'll totally do video
for that tomorrow the very first x-men
apocalypse trailer is also dropping I
have no idea when I think it's gonna
come in the morning so I'll just I'll
probably end up doing that video first
be sure to subscribe to get it if you
want updates on when all those videos
are coming you can follow me on Twitter
and Facebook there are links for that at
the bottom of the description so while
you wait for everything else to post you
can click here for my Captain America
civil war trailer video and you can
click here for my latest Star Wars
trailer it's probably the last big Star
Wars trailer before the actual movie
comes thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you